[Music]  terney the Katy Perry now she just  kicked off her world tour in Montreal  last night and here's what we witnessed  a lot of color and remember that famous  shark well he's back it's a fantastical  productions lots of color lots of worlds  lots of costume changes  hitties got six major costume changes  during her to our set from red sequins  to blue latex no detail is overlooked  even our mics match her outfits the  season performer covers 20 of her  greatest hits and take a look at those  sets super-sized pink telephones and a  Space Odyssey Katy's even bringing back  an old friend left shark in a nod to her  2015 Super Bowl halftime show I want  people to feel joy when they leave and I  also want them to feel inspired I'm  flying on a star - so much stuff is  happening  [Music]  you  [Music]